more than 50 million users worldwide
play games from luca company boss jens
begemann does not rely on
classic game consoles but on
tablet pcs and smartphones
yoga is the european market for social games with a colorful game world
we both have a game called
diamond dash and we try it  I have
60 seconds to tap as many
gems as possible with my finger
on the smartphone and I
'm in a tournament with my friends
that means I'm trying
to win the gold medal against my friends who are
competing in the same tournament
and that's actually that  special i
play with my friends and against
my friends
yes that's true over 90 percent of our
users never spend money on our
free games but i can
buy additional features within the game
for example in diamond
dash i can buy small additional boosters which give
me a small advantage  procure
and where I then in the tournament  my
friends maybe have the chance to keep the gold medal with a
little higher probability
we make games that i
can play in between
i can't require long
explanations and instructions game
i have to it has to be that
we don't start playing i
within the first one  or two
minutes already have fun and understand the game
and then there has to be an element
in the game which is so much
fun for me that I
come back every day and that's something that's
very, very difficult
to plan in advance that you have to
try